COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES WE GOT
THE SAME OLD SCRIPT HERE- IT
COMPLIED FOR THOSE ORDERS THE
STATE SENATE'S DESERT MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING IT FOR SERVICE
FOR THOSE IN TOOLS WHO TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE HE
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS COULD BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE A MUTED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY THE COMMITTEE WILL
ALLOW FOR TWO MAIN WITNESSES PER
SIDE IT WILL LIMIT EACH WITNESS
FOR TWO MINUTES WE'LL BE KEEPING
TRACK OF THE TIME SO MAKE SURE
YOU WERE BRIEF. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. MORE MAKE THAT CLEAR
AGAIN. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. WE WILL LIMIT THE ME
TWO TO TEN MINUTES TOTAL PER
SIDE. AFTER READING THE NUMBER
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT. YES
APPARENTLY I CUT OUT- AT THE
NUMBER TOOK. THE PARTICIPANTS OF
PHONE NUMBER TODAY IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. IN THAT ACCESS CODE
IS. FOUR SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT. I WILL MAINTAIN MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL'S
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. I DO WE HAVE A CORE. SO
LET'S DO THAT BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESS ANY PRESENTATIONS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DOT YOUR
DAUGHTER HERE NELSON NELSON HERE
ALAN ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HERE
BAKER. BAKER HERE FORGES
BRADFORD GLAZER WESO JONES.
JONES HERE CAN LONGER YOUR
MOTHER HERE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
HERE PORTING TO NOW RUBIO. RUBIO
PRESENT WILKE. WHAT IS PRESENT
WE HAVE A PRINTER SECTOR NOTES
CORMS BEEN ESTABLISHED WE'LL
BEGIN WITH OUR CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH INCLUDES FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO S. B. NINE TEN AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SPEAK TEN OH SEVEN
CAN DO THAT I'VE GOT A MOTION
FROM SENATOR- WILL MEMBERS- PUT
REMINDER TO PLEASE- WAIT TO HEAR
MIKE IS TURNED ON TO PLEASE
SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO THE MIKE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE NEED IS MIKE PLEASE. THANK
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS DIED. HI DOT HI NELSON
NELSON HI ALAN ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI BECKER. HI BECKER
HI GORGEOUS BRADFORD GLAZER WESO
JONES JONES HI KEN LONGER CAN
LONGER I MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW RUBIO.
RUBIO I WILL I WILL I AM
CONCERNED. THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES BUT- TALK CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- WE WILL BEGIN THE FILE
AND I'M NUMBER ONE SP EIGHT
FORTY SIX WHICH IS MY BILL SO I
WILL PASS THE GAVEL NOW TO OUR
VICE CHAIR CENTERED THE DEAN OF
THE SENATE SENATOR NIELSEN THANK
YOU R CHAIRMAN AND WE WILL NOW.
PRESENT S. B. EIGHT FOUR SIX IS
OUR FIRST BILL TODAY THE
CHAIRMAN PHIL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. S. B. EIGHT FORTY SIX
. SIX TO DO TWO MAJOR THINGS THE
FIRST IS TO EXPAND ON LAST
YEAR'S COCKTAIL TO GO BILL BY
ADDING BARS TO THOSE PROVISIONS
REMOVING THE MEAL REQUIREMENT
AND ALLOWING FOR DELIVERY OF
COCKTAILS DIRECT TO CONSUMER
STORE. WITH THOSE CHANGES THAT
PORTION OF S. B. EIGHT FORTY SIX
WOULD BE IDENTICAL TO MY BILL SB
THREE EIGHTY NINE FROM LAST YEAR
WHICH UNANIMOUSLY WAS PASSED IN
THIS COMMITTEE. THE ABILITY TO
INCLUDE ALCOHOLIC DRINKS HAS
BEEN A LIFELINE TO OUR
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY DURING
COVERT NINETEEN. THIS BILL
SIMPLY SEEKS TO CONTINUE ONE OF
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL ELEMENTS OF
THE EMERGENCY REGULATORY
PANDEMIC RELIEF. IN ADDITION
THIS BILL REQUIRES THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES WHO ARE
DELIVERING ALCOHOL ON BEHALF OF
THE LICENSEE TO OBTAIN A PERMIT
FROM ABC DEPARTMENT OF ABC. AS
THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE DEPARTMENT OF A.
B. C. HAS NO STATUTORY OVERSIGHT
OVER THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANIES THAT DELIVER ALCOHOL
THAT'S THE STATE OF AFFAIRS
TODAY. THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR THAT HE CANNOT
SANCTION THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANIES AND THEREFORE
RESPONSIBILITY IN ANY POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL LIABILITY. IS WITH THAT
WITH THE DRIVER- IN WITH THE
LICENSEE THAT SOLD ALCOHOL THAT
AND THAT IS CURRENT LAW. SB
FORTY SIX SOLVES THIS PROBLEM BY
SHIFTING SOME RESPONSIBILITY TO
THE THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANIES AND PROVIDING THE
DEPARTMENT BBC WITH OVERSIGHT OF
THOSE ALCOHOLDELIVERIES. ONCE
AGAIN WE WANT TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF ABC WITH OVERSIGHT
OVER THOSE ALCOHOL DELIVERIES. I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT THIS
DOES NOT LEGALIZE THE DELIVERY
OF ALCOHOL BY THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES BY EITHER
GROCERY STORES OR EVEN
RESTAURANTS. THAT'S THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT CURRENT LAW ALREADY
ALLOWS ALL TYPES OF ALCOHOL TO
BE DELIVERED BY THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANY. ON BEHALF OF
GROCERY STORES IN THE ABILITY OF
THESE COMPANIES TO DELIVER WHAT
A BEER ON BEHALF OF RESTAURANTS
. WHAT THIS BILL ISWHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS PROVIDE A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT BBC THE NECESSARY
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
DELIVERIES ARE BEING DONE IN A
RESPONSIBLE MANNER. THAT
PROTECTS AGAINST UNDER AGE
DRINKING AND OVER INTOXICATION.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
DELIVERY DRIVERS WHO ARE
DELIVERING ALCOHOL TO COMPLETED
TRAINING IT MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF ABC CAN
SUSPEND OR REVOKE A CONSUMER
DELIVERY SERVICE PERMIT WHEN
CIRCUMSTANCES WARRANT SUCH
DISCIPLINE IN IT AUTHORIZES ABC.
TO IMPOSE FINES ON THE HOLDER OF
THE PERMIT. BEFORE I CLOSE I
WANT TO ADDRESS THE LETTER OF
OPPOSITION THAT LABOR SENT OUT
FRIDAY AFTERNOON. NOT ONLY WAS
THIS SENT OUT AFTER THE ANALYSIS
WAS COMPLETED BUT WAS SET MORE
THAN TWO MONTHS AFTER THE BILL
WAS INTRODUCED. THAT ALONE IS
FRUSTRATING. WHAT MAKES IT WORSE
IS THE CLAIMS MADE BY THAT
LETTER. ARE MISLEADING
MISLEADING TO SAY THE LEAST IT
OFTEN. SO OFTEN TIMES SIMPLY
FACTUALLY INCORRECT YES B. E.
FORTY SIX DOES NOT SHIP
LIABILITIES FROM RETAILERS TO
DRIVERS AS THE OPPOSITION
CLAIMED IN THEIR LETTER. AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THE BILL
WOULD SHIP SOME RESPONSIBILITIES
FROM RETAILERS AND RESTAURANTS
THE THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANIES NOT DRIVERS. THE
LETTER CLAIMS THAT THIS BILL IS
UNCLEAR WHO THE PENALTY FALLS ON
AGAIN IT'S THE ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT THESE FALLS WOULD FALL ON
THIRD PARTY DELIVERY COMPANIES
THAT'S ON PAGE FOUR LINE
SEVENTEEN AND IT MAKES IT
PERFECTLY CLEAR. FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T BELIEVE ME I WELCOME THEM
TO READ THE BILL OR READ THE
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL IF THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH I SUGGEST REACHING
OUT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF ABC SO
THE DEPARTMENT CAN PROVIDE THEM
WITH AN UNBIASED OPINION. THE
LETTER ALSO CLAIMS IN ANOTHER
STATE. THE EXTENT ALCOHOL TO GO
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS HAVE
INSISTED ON EMPLOYEE STATUS.
THEN USE A BILL PASSED IN
GEORGIA IS AN EXAMPLE OF SUCH
CLAIMS. BY COMMITTEE STAFF SPENT
TIME OVER THE LAST COUPLE DAYS
REVIEWING EACH D. EIGHT SEVENTY
NINE THE GEORGIA BILL THAT
OPERATES ALCOHOL TO GO IN
MEMBERS THE BILL DOES NO SUCH
THING. WHAT GEORGIA BILL DOES
IT'S THE SAME THING THAT HAS TO
BE EIGHT FORTY SIX WEEKS TO DO.
IT ALLOWS FOR ALCOHOL TO BE
DELIVERED BY EITHER AN EMPLOYEE
OR A LICENSEE OR BY A THIRD
PARTY DELIVERY COMPANY.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE GEORGIA
BUILD US I'VE ALWAYS VIEWED
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER NOT A
FOLLOWER. BUT MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO BE VERY CLEAR THE MY
FRUSTRATION IS NOT WITH THE FACT
THAT THERE IS OPPOSITION. TO MY
BILL. I WELCOME ANY AND ALL FAIR
CRITICISM. WHAT I DON'T
APPRECIATE IT FOR CERTAIN GROUPS
TO USE THEIR POLITICAL CLOUT. TO
MISLEAD MEMBERS AND MAKE A
MOCKERY OUT OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. FINALLY MEMBERS THE
LETTER ARGUES THAT IN THE
ABSENCE OF EMPLOYEE STATUS THE
LEGISLATURE MUST ENSURE
PENALTIES DO NOT FALL ON THE
BACKS OF VULNERABLE WORKERS AND
THAT THERE'S NEEDS TO BE A
ROBUST LICENSING STRUCTURE SO
THE COMPANY'S LICENSES CONSUMER
DELIVERY SERVICE IN THE STATE.
ACTUALLY KERRY THE LIABILITY. I
AGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT MY
BILL DOES WITH ME TODAY IS KATIE
HANSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND JOHN LATIMER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION. NOW THEN
PROCEED TO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
OTHERS AND YOU MENTIONED MR-
KATIE HANSON. AND IF YOU HAVE
ONE OTHER ONE MISTER JOHN
LATIMER. MISS HANSON ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. I'M YES SENATOR IN
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS GOOD
MORNING. PLEASE PROCEED GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KATIE
HANSON THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY EIGHT FOUR SIX THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU WOULD SIMPLY
RESTORE THE ABILITY OF
RESTAURANT PATRONS TO PURCHASE
COCKTAILS FROM A RESTAURANT AS
PART OF THEIR DELIVERY ORDER.
THE SAME POLICY WAS ALLOWED
UNDER TEMPORARY ABC EMERGENCY
RELIEF AT THE OUTSET OF THE
PANDEMIC AND HAS SINCE CEASED
GIVEN THAT THE SAME ABC
REGULATORY RELIEF WAS IN PLACE
FOR OVER A YEAR THE POLICY
MODERNIZATION IN EIGHTY EIGHT
FOUR SIX HAS HAD A GOOD LONG
TRIAL PERIOD. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. IT'S ACTUALLY ACTING
AS A SUCCESSFUL PILOT PROJECT.
IN ADDITION TO RESTORING THE
PRIVILEGE OF ALLOWING COCKTAILS
TO BE PROVIDED FROM RESTAURANTS
VIA DELIVERY. EIGHTY EIGHT FOUR
SIX ALSO EXPANDS CONSUMER CHOICE
BY NOT REQUIRING TAKEOUT OR
DELIVERY ORDERS AND THESE
PRODUCTS TO A COMPANY AND MEAL.
EIGHTY EIGHT FOUR SIX EVEN GOES
ONE STEP FURTHER AND I WAS
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY. THE POLICY WAS
APPROVED BY THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR AS WELL AS BY THE FULL
SENATE BODY. WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT HERE TODAY FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR SIX. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS HANSON HAS WRITTEN
TO MISTER JOHN LATIMER. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN LATIMER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S RETAILERS HAVE BEEN
USING THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANIES TO MAKE DELIVERIES
INCLUDING ALCOHOL SALES FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. AS THE CHAIRMAN
SAID CONTRARY TO THE
OPPOSITION'S POSITION THIS IS
NOT A NEW AUTHORITY AND THIS IS
NOT NEW AUTHORITY BEING GRANTED
THIS BILL THIS BILL ACTUALLY
CLOSES AN IMPORTANT ENFORCEMENT
GAP IN THE ABC'S OF THE WORDING.
BECAUSE THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
COMPANIES ARE NOT ALCOHOL
LICENSEES THE ABC CANNOT AFFORD
ENFORCE AGAINST THE COMPANY. IF
A DELIVERY IS MADE TO A MINOR
INTOXICATED PERSON IRONICALLY
THE ONLY OPTIONS THEN LEFT IT TO
THE A. B. C. R. TO ENFORCE
AGAINST THE RETAILER EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE MADE NO MISTAKE IN THE
PROCESS OR THE DRIVER
THEMSELVES. THERE IS AUTHORITY
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO ENFORCE
AGAINST THE DRIVER THAT'S NOT
CREATED BY THIS THAT'S IN THE
PENAL CODE WHEN PROVIDING
ALCOHOL TO A MINOR IS AGAINST
THE LAW. SO EVEN THOUGH THE
OPPOSITION IS CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT THIS BILL MAY DO RELATIVE
TO THE DRIVERS IT ACTUALLY HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THE
DRIVERS AND AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROTECT THE RETAIL COMMUNITY AND
MOVE THE RESPONSIBILITY WHERE IT
BELONGS TO A THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANY. IF A MISTAKE
IS MADE. SO THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY BY CLOSING THE GAP
REQUIRES COMPANIES TO SECURE A
PERMIT FROM THE A. B. C. IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO BE A THIRD
PARTY COMPANY DELIVERING ALL
CALL. THESE COMPANIES HAVE TO
FOLLOW A PRESCRIBED SET OF
POLICIES AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS THAT A FUTURE
DELIVERY MISTAKES ARE FIRST
MINIMIZED AND IF THEY'RE MADE
THEY CAN BE PURSUED AGAINST THE
DELIVERY COMPANY THEMSELVES.
THIS IS AGAIN A POLICY BEING
ADOPTED IN NUMEROUS STATES.
EVERY PARTNERSHIPS CONTINUE TO
BE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
RETELLING CALIFORNIA YES THIS IS
THIS IS INCREASED IN THE
PANDEMIC BUT IT WAS ALREADY.
THEIR RELATIONSHIP AND IN
EXISTENCE WELL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC WE JUST GREW TO RELY ON
IT MORE AND MORE BALL THAT'S
COMPANIES AND AS CONSUMERS. C.
R. A. FEELS VERY STRONGLY TO
DELIVER COMPANIES. OUR PARTNERS
BUT THEY SHOULD ALSO HAVE
APPROPRIATE STATE PERMITS IT
HERE TO OUR STATE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT SHOULD
THEY MAKE A MISTAKE. THOSE
COMPANIES SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY THE ABC FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE DRIVING. THANK
YOU MR LATIMER DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE. IN THE CHAMBER WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. GLAD WE HAVE
A MEMBER OF. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I JUST WANNA COMMIT
THE AUTHOR BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
YOU WORKED A LOT ON THIS BILL TO
TRY AND. I'M SORRY TO THE
POSITION. NO NO NO NO I'M SORRY
IT IS THE OPPOSITION THAT'S TO
SPEAK NOT A MEMBER MODERATOR DO
YOU HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO INDIA TO KEEP THAT
. BEGIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. HER FIRST
PLANE NUMBER SEVENTEEN LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY IS
THIS GOVERNANCE I HAD SOME
TROUBLE GETTING THE BOTTOM LINE
AM I IN GOVERNANCE. THE
GOVERNANCE COMMITTEE AND THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE IT IS I WANT
TO BE SURE I'M IN THE RIGHT
PLACE- GOOD OKAY WELL I THINK TO
SUPPORT ENDING THE EMERGENCY BUT
I'M TOTALLY CONFUSED BECAUSE YOU
PEOPLE ARE YOU ASKING ON AND ON
ABOUT ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES WHILE
CALIFORNIA DIES AND WE DIDN'T
UNDER THE- THE GAS TAX YESTERDAY
WHAT ARE YOU PEOPLE DOING DOWN
THERE. SUCH A WASTE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS IS OF THE WASTE OF OUR
MONEY AND- COMMENTING ON THE- I
SAID EVERY MAN WOULD YOU COMMENT
ON. THE BILL. SPEAK TO THE BILL
SHE'S. HE'S ON THE OTHER. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. MODERATOR WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE ON THE LINE
WHO MAY BE WISHING TO SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATION DO YOU HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. WISHING TO SUPPORT. WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL LINE
LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
SOMETHING LIKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ABOUT A FIAT FIVE BOATING. I
BELIEVE THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
SOMETHING LIKE WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO WRONG WITH A MAN. THROWING
BEER WE'RE ON S. B. EIGHT FOUR
SIX SENATOR DODD. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL LINES AT THIS TIME.
WE SHOULD HAVE YEAH. MA'AM THIS
IS NOT THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
WISHING TO TESTIFY ON. MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN QUEUE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
FOUR SIX. WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
LINES AT THE TIME ALL RIGHT. DO
WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. IN THE
CHAMBER. IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
SOMEBODY UP THERE PLEASE PROCEED
. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
NOT OVERLOOK TO RECORD WE HAVE A
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS. REGRETTABLE OPPOSITION
FIRST OF ALL LET ME START BY-
APOLOGIZING FOR THE LATE
SUBMISSION OF OUR OPPOSITION
LETTER LATE LAST WEEK- THE
LETTER WAS SUBMITTED AS SOON AS
THE BILL WAS. NOTICED FOR
HEARING A SECOND I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT- ALTHOUGH THE LETTER
WHAT WAS SUBMITTED LATE. ANOTHER
YOU HAVE TO GO BE ANOTHER AND
TEACHERS THE LABOR FOR OTHERS
HAVE BEEN AN ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
WITH YOUR OFFICE AROUND THIS
POLICY WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF-
TO PRINEVILLE US- PREPARED TO
CONFER ABOUT THE MERITS OF THIS
YEAR'S BILL. FIRST OF ALL I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT. THE LEGAL AND-
I THINK IT'S UNDISPUTED THAT THE
LEGAL. AND REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
IN THIS IN THIS AREA IS
UNSETTLED- YOUR BILL WAS PASSED
LAST YEAR MR DODD. SIGNED INTO
LAW WENT INTO EFFECT JANUARY
FIRST HAS A FIVE YEAR SUNSET.
PRESIDENT TWENTY TWO. WHICH IF
IT'S RATED THE CUSTOMER
RESPONDED SUPERIOR. IS ALSO IN
DISPUTE IT'S CURLY LITIGATION
NOT CLEAR WHAT THOSE FINAL
RESULTS WILL BE OF THAT I BRING
THAT UP ONLY IN THE CONTEXT OF
THIS NOTION OF WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE WHO WHO IS LIABLE
WHO SHOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR MISTAKES. AMERICAN
JURISPRUDENCE CALIFORNIA LAW HAS
BEEN CONSISTENT WHEN IT COMES TO
PRODUCT LIABILITY. WE THOUGHT
WE'VE ALWAYS FELT THAT THE CHAIN
OF LIABILITY RUNS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH. FROM FROM THE
PRODUCTION OF THE PRODUCT ALL
THE WAY TO THE CONCERNS OF THE
PRODUCT. THIS BILL CONTINUES TO
EVISCERATE THAT CHAIN OF
LIABILITY THE CHALLENGE BECOMES
NUMBER ONE AS BEEN STATED BY THE
AUTHOR. WHAT HAPPENS. VOCALIST
SOLD TO MINORS I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE RETAILERS DON'T WANT THE
LIABILITY. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
WAY PRODUCT LIABILITY WORKS IN
THIS COUNTRY IF THERE IS THE
REASON THAT THE CHANGES. THE
CHAIN REMAINS UNBROKEN IS TO
ASSURE. THE VICTIMS HAVE A
RECOURSE THAT THAT THAT IS THE
ENTIRE PURPOSE OF PRODUCT
LIABILITY AND THIS BILL WOULD
RESTRICT THAT FINALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS OF U. F. C. W. WE ARE
VERY MUCH CONCERNED. ABOUT THE
CHERRY PICKING OF PRODUCTS FROM
GROCERY STORES. THIS THIS HASN'T
A DENTIST IT'S BEGINNING TO HAVE
A DEVASTATING EFFECT ON THE
GROCERY STORES AND THEIR
PROFITABILITY THE DELIVERY
COMPANIES. CAN HIRE THESE
DRIVERS THEY DON'T CHARACTERIZE
THEM AS EMPLOYEES. THEY HAVE
MAJOR ADVANTAGES WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ECONOMICS OF THE
SITUATION. AND THE GROCERY
STORES ARE HIGHLY DEPENDENT. ON
FOOT TRAFFIC COMING TO STORES IF
YOU IF YOU GO TO A GROCERY STORE
YOU KNOW THAT. IF YOU'RE GOING
TO BUY A BUY ONE ITEM TO CARMEL.
YOU NEVER LEAVE ON ONE ITEM. HE
ALSO NOTICED THAT IN GROCERY
STORES. ALCOHOL IS NOT PLACED UP
FROM THE STORE I'LL CALL A
STRATEGICALLY PLACED AT THE BACK
OF STORE SO PEOPLE AREN'T GOING
TO STORES. SEVEN THE FACT THAT
CUSTOMERS MAY NO LONGER HAVE
COME INTO THE GROCERY STORES
HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT.ON
THESE GO TO STORES AND AN
EMERGENCY W. RESPECT FOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CONVEY
RESPECT. WE HAVE FOR NOT THE
NOBLE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER. PRIMARY WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION. HI YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE CHAIR AND RANKING
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME
IS CARSON BENOWITZ FREDERICKS
I'M THE RESEARCH DIRECTOR
ALCOHOL JUSTICE IN SAN RAFAEL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU VOTE
NO ON SB EIGHT FORTY SIX. I DO
FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE SEEN IT HERE
BEFORE AND WE'VE READ A LITANY.
OF FACTS ABOUT THE HARMS OF
ALCOHOL IN CALIFORNIA- I'M GONNA
DO IT AGAIN BUT YOU KNOW AT SOME
POINT THEY SHOULD BE. INCLUDED
IN EVERY DIRECTORY BILL THAT
COMES BEFORE- THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD COME FROM DPH NOT US. BUT
THE BIG ONE I WANT TO POINT OUT
IS YOU KNOW IT YOU'VE HEARD ME
SAY. THAT THERE HAVE BEEN TEN
THOUSAND DEATHS ANNUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA- I'M ALCOHOL HARM
WELL IT'S- THAT'S BEEN- THAT'S
BEEN REVISED IT'S NOW ELEVEN
THOUSAND- IT'S STILL GOING UP-
WE KNOW THAT- DEATHS FROM
ALCOHOL RELATED DISEASE ARE
SPIKING ESPECIALLY IN YOUNG
AMERICANS. SO WE KNOW WHAT
ALCOHOL HARM CONTINUES TO BE AN
ESCALATING. NOT DIMINISHING
PROBLEM. HOT AND LOCKDOWN
LOCKDOWN HAS EXACERBATED THIS WE
KNOW THE FIVE YEAR ROLLING
AVERAGE ALKYLATED CRASHES ROSE
IN TWENTY TWENTY. DESPITE
LIMITATIONS ON MOVEMENT AND WE
KNOW FROM A- UNIVERSES KAGO
ANALYSIS THAT. THE OBSERVED
RATES RATE OBSERVED RATE OF
INCREASE IN ALCOHOL RELATED
DEATHS- RIGHT. 25% MORE THAN IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. BASED ON THE-
BEFORE LOCKED. HI WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THIS TIME WHILE WE DID
YOU WRAP IT UP SIR. YOU'RE RIGHT
PLEASE YOUR RAMBLING A BIT STAY
ON POINT PLEASE. OKAY. THESE
HARMS OCCURRED WHILE WE WERE
INCREASING DELIVERY WHY WE'RE
DEREGULATING ALCOHOL AND WE ARE
NOW TRYING TO MAKE. THESE ITEMS
PERMANENT SPECIFICALLY TO THIS
BILL- WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST CHANGE WHERE THE
LIABILITY IS THIS REMOVES LARGE
SECTIONS OF LIABILITY THERE IS
ACTUALLY RESPONSIBILITY FOR OUR
CALL SERVICE TO NOT SELL IN
CERTAIN SITUATIONS BESIDES JUST
UNDER AGE BRANCH YOU WOULD BE
DANGEROUS SOME POP HAPPENED UP.
THERE IN THIS. PLEASE WRAP IT UP
YOU'VE HAD A LOT OF VERBIAGE OF
COURSE HI AND THEN THIS ALSO
CREATES THE- SITUATION WHICH WE
HAVE GOES BARS ACTUALLY RUN WITH
SKELETON STAFFS REDUCED THE
NUMBER OF POOR BOYS THEY CAN
HAVE UNDER A LIQUOR LICENSE. AND
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WHAT THEY'RE SELLING GOES
OUT THERE. AGAIN EVERY BUILD
LIKE THIS SIR I SEE THAT BUT-
AUSTIN WE JUST LIGHTLY ASK YOU
VOTE NO. ON SB. EIGHT FORTY SIX
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. MY
PROCTOR DES SAY THAT THE FORMER
MEMBER ALBERTO TO RICO. IS GOING
TO SPEAK ALSO FOR UFCW. PARDON
OVER THE- ONE MR OKAY ALL RIGHT
ANY OTHER PEOPLE IN Q. ERROR IN
HERE THAT WANTS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED. THANK
YOU. ANYMORE YES MR CHEER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL
SKIPPER REPRESENTING YOU FOR
JUSTICE SANDRA FELL AS WELL AS
BEST START REGION ONE COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP REPRESENTING FOR LA
COMMUNITIES EAST BOSS ANGELUS
METRO LOS ANGELES SOUTHEAST LA.
AND EL MONTE. AND SOUTH EL MONTE
ON BEHALF OF YOUTH CHILDREN NECK
AND FAMILIES PLEASE VOTE NO. WE
HAVE ONE MORE UNDERSTOOD I
UNDERSTAND HERE IN THE CHAMBER
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION FACE. GOOD
MORNING- CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MY DOCUMENT AS I'M
SPEAKING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALCOHOL POLICY ALLIANCE THE OVER
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS A PREVENTION
PROFESSIONALS AND PROMOTE
THOUGHT AS WE REPRESENT OUR
CONCERN FOR A. B. C.'S ALCOHOL
DELIVERY DECOY VIOLATION RATE OF
20% REPORTED LAST MONTH THIS
BILL IS THE ALCOHOL INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX KNOCKING ON THE DOOR.
WELL YOU OPEN THE DOOR OR KEEP
IT OUTSIDE YOU HAVE THE CHOICE
TO DECIDE BACK TODAY WE NEED
COMMUNITY TO BE REPRESENTED
PUBLIC HEALTH INEQUITY NEEDS TO
BE AT THE TABLE DATA NEEDS TO BE
AT THE TABLE NO NO ON SB EIGHT
FORTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
CALLING IN IN QUEUE TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY. OPERATORS CAN
DETERMINE IF YOU WOULD. LIKE TO
SHOW OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO ZERO. YOUR FIRST LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HM NUMBER HANG
DUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS- WE SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE U. S.
T. W. AND ONE OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. DESERT CAN CONSTITUTE ALL
OF THE OPPOSITION. MODERATOR
WELL WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL LINE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE THESE. WELL
THE LINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS FRED JONES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
ON ALCOHOL PROBLEMS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WE WILL NOW THEN MOVED TO THE
CHAMBER AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
PUBLISHED ONE MEMBER WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK. CENTER RUBIO. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN- A YES AT FIRST
OF ALL I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR BECAUSE I KNOW THAT LAST
YEAR I BELIEVE IT WAS LAST YEAR
YOU WORKED- REALLY DILIGENTLY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF MY CONCERNS- IN
PARTICULAR THE ISSUE FOR ME
LAST. TIME WAS PRETTY SAFE
AROUND CHILDREN GETTING THEIR
HANDS ON ALL CALL HALL AND I
THINK. YOU'VE A TACKLE THAT
ISSUE IN PARTICULAR BY ADDING A
NEW CONSUMER TRAINING FACTOR
PARTY DELIVERY WHICH INCLUDES-
EDUCATING ON THE SOCIAL IMPACTS
OF ALCOHOL AS WELL AS THE IMPACT
ON THE BODY- FOCUSING ON STATE
AND FEDERAL. LAW AS WELL AS- OUR
LEARNING TECHNIQUES TO PREVENT
THE CELL TOO INTOXICATED
INDIVIDUAL CELL I THINK THAT WAS
AN IMPORTANT PART AND EVEN
THOUGH IT DID PASS YOU NONE OF
MYSTERY FOR ME- IT WAS PART OF
THE EMERGENCY PANDEMIC RELIEF
THAT WE WERE DOING FOR
BUSINESSES AND I STILL BELIEVE
WE CAN DO THAT. UNFORTUNATES NOT
SOMETHING I BELIEVE YOU
DETERMINE I THINK IT WAS AN
AMENDMENT THAT WAS ASKED OF YOU
WHICH WAS TO REMOVE THAT
DELIVERY OF FOOD ALONG WITH THE
ALCOHOL AND I'M STILL STRUGGLING
WITH THAT BECAUSE I WANT TO
SUPPORT OUR BUSINESSES- AS YOU
ORDER A MEAL YOU ORDER YOUR MEAL
WITH A WITH A COCKTAIL. BUT THE
REMOVAL OF THE MEAL IS WHAT I'M
STRUGGLING WITH AND BECAUSE YOU
KNOW AS A FORMER COUNCIL MEMBER
I DO RECOGNIZE THAT. WE MAY BE
DISADVANTAGING SOME OF OUR LOCAL
STORES BECAUSE INSTEAD OF GOING
OUT TO BUY IN OUR LOCAL STORES
YOU JUST ORDER FROM A RESTAURANT
SO AGAIN I'M STILL STRUGGLING A
LITTLE BIT WITH THAT I WANT TO
GIVE THE TERM AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD AND CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS SAID SO I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE MY CONCERNS AND ALL BUT I
KNOW YOU'VE WORKED HARD ON THIS
UNFORTUNATELY AMENDMENT SOMEONE
MADE TO TAKE NOW REMOVES THAT
THE FOOD PART OF IT AND SO I
WANTED TO SEE WE CAN EXPLORE
THAT FURTHER. BUT I WILL. VOTE
FOR TODAY AND HOPE. THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION THANK
YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
MEMBER. OF THE G. COMMITTEE.
WISHING COMMENT. YES CENTER
PORTENT TINA YES SIR I JUST WANT
TO- ECHO CONCERNS ABOUT MAKING
SURE WE HAVE SAFEGUARDS AROUND
USED CAR I DON'T KNOW IF WE TALK
ABOUT COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE WE
GONNA ALLOW DELIVERY TO COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND OTHER SITUATIONS
WHERE YOU KNOW THERE MIGHT BE
OTHER ISSUE SO- I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH SAID THE AUTHOR
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES-
IF THE BILL GETS OUT TODAY. IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WHICH I ASSUME IT'S WHERE IT'S
GONNA GO NEXT AND- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS- YOU KNOW I HEAR
THE LABOR CONCERNS AND I HEAR
THE CHAIR YOU KNOW MENTIONING
THAT YOU KNOW SOME OF IT IS NOT
TO JERMAINE AND SO WE'LL HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AS THIS
BOOK. CONTINUES TO MOVE. THANK
YOU SENATOR FORTINO ANY OTHER
MEMBERS HERE WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
. PLEASE DIRECT THE CHAIR BUT
YET JUST TO ECHO SOME OF THE-
POINTS MADE FOR SPOKE TO DO YOU
APPRECIATE THIS PAIR THIS BILL
TO HELP OUR RESTAURANTS HAVE
STRUGGLED SO MUCH DURING COVE IT
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE FOOD ISSUE RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUE AS WELL AS- MAKING
SURE PROTECTIONS AROUND COLLEGE
CAMPUSES AND OTHER. KINDS OF
DELIVERIES AND BEGIN SENSITIVE
TO CONCERNS OF OUR- THAT WERE
RAISED BY OUR FRIENDS IN LABOR
AND I DON'T THINK GENERALLY
PEOPLE WOULD WANNA PAY
RESTAURANT MARKET JUST TO AVOID.
A MAN YOU KNOW HAVING TO GO TO A
STORE BUT WHEN YOU MOVE THE
FOOD. ASPECT IT DOES CONCERN ME
A BIT SO AGAIN I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BEFORE TO
THINK IT'S VERY GOOD IN SPIRIT.
AND LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR. YES ONE I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO GIVE THE
AUTHOR CHAIR- THE COURTESY OF
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS I GOT A
CHANCE TO- PRETTY BIG WINDOW
INTO THE SOME OF THE
COMPLEXITIES HERE- WHEN WE WERE
WORKING ON A BILL THAT'S NOW
OVER ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE- BUT I
CERTAINLY- HOPE THAT- THAT THESE
LABOR ISSUES AND- AND MINOR
ISSUES YOUTH ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED WILL BE WILL BE
WORKED OUT THROUGH THE COURSE OF
THIS NEGOTIATION BUT I
UNDERSTAND. AND YOU GOT A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO ARE POSITIONING AND I
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA BE WORKING
HARD TO TRY TO COME UP WITH A
NEGATIVE A SOLUTION HERE MISTER
CHAIR. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS HERE WISHING TO QUESTION
COMMENT. SENATOR ARCHULETA YEAH
I MISSED YOUR- I'M I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LABOR ISSUES
AND UNTIL THEY GET RESOLVED I'M
GONNA HAVE TO LAY OFF. THANK
YOU. YES THEN- WELL. CHAIR I
MOVE THE BILL WE HAVE A MOTION
DO YOU WISH TO MAKE A CALL
CENTER DI YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I HEARD NOTHING IN THE
OPPOSITION- THAT CHANGES YOU
KNOW ANYTHING THAT I DO AND I
YOU KNOW PEOPLE EVEN IN LABOR
I'VE TALKED TO THEM BOTH THE
PEOPLE LAST NIGHT. I STILL
BELIEVE THAT THE THINGS THAT
THEY'RE BRINGING UP ARE PRETTY
FAR FETCHED BUT- NEVERTHELESS
WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT TO
SENATOR PORTMAN TINO'S POINT
ABOUT COLLEGE CAMPUSES THIS BILL
DOESN'T IT RIGHT NOW AS WE'VE
POINTED OUT ALCOHOL CAN BE
DELIVERED RIGHT NOW. THE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES THIS BILL DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING TO CHANGE THAT BUT I'M
HAPPY- I YOU KNOW THOSE SOMEBODY
THAT HAS. A LOT OF KIDS
GRANDKIDS AND EVERYTHING I THINK
THAT- YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE WORKED ON SO I WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
SENATOR PORTENT TINO- THAT THE-
AS FAR AS THE FOOD ISSUE- THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WE HEARD FROM
THE RESTAURANT BUSINESS AND
FRANKLY THE BAR BUSINESS AS WELL
THE BARS WANTED YOU OUT TO HAVE
THIS PRIVILEGED TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THEIR BUSINESSES. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE FOOD THAT
THE RESTAURANT STAFF AND THEN
WE'VE ALSO HAD COMPLAINTS ABOUT
THE OUT AND OUT EXPENSE OF YES
SOMETIMES OR IN THE FOOD ADD
GIVING CONSUMERS THE ABILITY TO
CHOOSE WHAT FOOD THEY WHAT THEY
MIGHT WANT TO GO COCKTAILS FROM
THIS RESTAURANT AND GET TO GO
FOOD FROM ANOTHER ONE THIS BILL
JUST DOESN'T REQUIRE YOU DOES
IT. DOESN'T TELL THE CONSUMER
WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO BUT IT'S TO
SENATOR RUBIO'S POINT I'M HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU- AS IS HIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD I THANK YOU FOR
THAT CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR
THAT KINDLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS CENTER DIED AND WE HAVE A
MOTION. BY SENATOR WELL. ACTIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FOLLOWING HIM ONE S. B. A. FORTY
SIX MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS DOT. DOT HI
NELSON HIGH NELSON HI ALAN.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA BECKER BAKER
HI GORGEOUS BRADFORD GLAZER WESO
. WEST SO HI JONES JONES HI KEN
LONGER MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I
POURED INTO NOW. ACCORDING TO
KNOW I. RUBIO WILL I WILL I WILL
CRY ON CULTURE MEN. WILL MOVE
THE CALL MISTER CHAIRMAN I
RETURNED TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR NELSON. WE'LL
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR S. C. R. FIVE BY SENATOR
MELINDA'S. CENTER MELINDA'S YOU
MAY PRESENT AT C. R. FIVE GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS THIS
RESOLUTION DECLARES THAT THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY RELATING TO
THE CABIN NINETEEN PANDEMIC
PROCLAIMED BY THE GOVERNOR ON
MARCH FOURTH OF TWENTY TWENTY IS
AT AN END THEREBY TERMINATING
THE EMERGENCY POWERS GRANTED TO
THE GOVERNOR PURSUANT TO THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN UNDER A
STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED DAYS DURING THAT
TIME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN
RESPONDING IN MITIGATING THE
SPREAD OF CODED BASED UPON THEIR
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE IN INFECTION
RATES. AS INFECTION AND
HOSPITALIZATION RATES CONTINUE
TO DROP IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE
TO ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
TAKE THE LEAD AND ADDRESS
EMERGENCIES LOCALLY WITHOUT THE
SHOT GUN APPROACH OF A STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY IT IS TIME THAT WE AS
A LEGISLATURE. HEED THE ADVICE
GIVEN TO US BY THE LA GO TO
JEALOUSLY GUARD ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE IN AUTHORITY
. THE GOVERNOR. HAS SLOWLY.
FOR NOW IT IS IN A TRULY IN A
BETTER PLACE TO HANDLE FUTURE
EVENTS LIKE COATED. THEN IT
SHOULD ALLOW EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE TO BE DETERMINED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL JUST LIKE WE DO
FOR EVERY OTHER EMERGENCY.
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION EIGHTY
SIX TWENTY NINE PROVIDES THAT
ALL OF THE POWERS GRANTED THE
GOVERNOR BY THIS CHAPTER WITH
RESPECT TO A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
SHOP TERMINATE WHEN THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY HAS BEEN TERMINATED BY
PROCLAMATION OF THE GOVERNOR. OR
BY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION AT THE
LEGISLATURE DECLARING IT AT AN
END THIS RESOLUTION MAKES THAT
DECLARATION WITH REGARD TO THE
CABIN NINETEEN PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY. THE GOVERNOR HAS COME
CLOSE OR POSSIBLY HAS VIOLATED
THE CONSTITUTIONAL SEPARATION OF
POWERS DOCTRINE BY LEGISLATING
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ORDER. IN FACT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL DOCTRINE OF
SEPARATION OF POWERS BETWEEN THE
THREE BRANCHES EXECUTIVE
LEGISLATIVE AND JUDICIAL IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IS QUITE
CLEAR AND ECLIPSES THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT. EVEN IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES STRICT SEPARATION OF
POWERS EXIST BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH AND EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
LEGISLATING IS THE PLENARY POWER
OF THE LEGISLATURE WHETHER IN
TIMES OF EMERGENCY OR NOT ONE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT CANNOT TAKE
ON A PRINCIPAL ROLE OF ANOTHER
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT A DOCTOR IN
WHICH BY THE WAY IS REINFORCED
BY THE SUPREME COURT. EVEN THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS
RECOGNIZED THIS FACT AGAIN THEIR
QUOTE WAS WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO JEALOUSLY GUARD
ITS CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE AND
AUTHORITY. SAID THIS RESOLUTION
SCR FIVE IS THE MANIFESTATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE REASSERTING ITS
PLENARY TO LEGISLATE AS WELL AS
ITS CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE AND
AUTHORITY. CONTINUED LOCKDOWNS
IN THE DESTRUCTION OF SMALL
BUSINESSES IS IT NOT THE ANSWER
TO SOLVING THE SPREAD OF CODE
NINETEEN. THE ARBITRARY NATURE
OF WHO IS CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL
AND WHAT BUSINESSES ARE ALLOWED
TO REMAIN OPEN NEEDS TO END
THERE ARE TOO MANY PEOPLE
SUFFERING ECONOMICALLY
PHYSICALLY AND MENTALLY TO
INCLUDE OUR CHILDREN AS A RESULT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S ACTIONS IT IS
TIME. FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO RE
ASSERT ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY
OF THIS STATE AND END THIS
ANALYSTS EMERGENCY- ONE FINAL
NOTE IS THAT THE CODE NINETEEN
CRISIS HAS RESULTED IN THE MOST
EXTREME ACTIVATION OF THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT SINCE
WORLD WAR TWO IF NOT EVER THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT HAS NOT
BEEN INVOKED ON SUCH A WIDE
SCALE IN MODERN TIMES IT WAS
WRITTEN TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC
TYPES OF EMERGENCIES LIKE FIRES
EARTHQUAKES WAR TERRORISM THINGS
OF THAT NATURE IS IN FACT IN
MANYWAYS THE EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT IS OBSOLETE IT WAS WRITTEN.
TO ADDRESS A POTENTIAL NUCLEAR
WAR DISASTER WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT AND MOST OF THE
BUREAUCRATIC MACHINATIONS OF
THIS STATE WERE DESTROYED OR
DEAD THE CODE NINETEEN CRISIS IS
NO SUCH DISASTER THE GOVERNING
BODIES OF THIS STATE ARE FULLY
FUNCTIONAL. THE ONGOING KEVIN
NINETEEN EMERGENCIES A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TYPE OF
EMERGENCY THAN WAS ENVISIONED.
WHEN EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT WAS
CONCEIVED THIS RESOLUTION
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REASSERT ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO
LEGISLATE UNDER THE SEPARATION
OF POWERS DOCTRINE AND ALLOW
MEMBERS TO EXPRESS THEIR
CONCERNS WITH THE WAY THE
ONGOING INDICATIONS OF THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACTIVE
MISSIONS. THE LEGISLATOR
PROVOCATIVE THIS IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL CENTERS.
TODAY I HAVE BUT ONE WITNESS
LAURA POWELL FROM THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR GOOD GOVERNANCE
FOR GOOD GOVERNANCE EXCUSE ME I
ASK THAT MEMBERS PLEASE PLEASE
GIVE HER YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
. THE SPELL GO AHEAD. YOUR
MORNING PORTER I'M LAURA POWELL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS FOR
GOOD GOVERNANCE A COALITION OF
VOTERS WHO WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW THIS PROLONGED STATE OF
EMERGENCY IS ERODING DEMOCRATIC
NORMS IN OUR STATE. ALTHOUGH WE
ARE NON PARTISAN. MANY OF US ARE
LONG TIME DEMOCRATS WHO NOW CALL
OURSELVES POLITICALLY HOMELESS
BECAUSE WE NO LONGER SEE OUR
PARTY STANDING UP FOR SOME OF
OUR CORE VALUES. I PERSONALLY
HAVE BEEN A REGISTERED DEMOCRAT
FOR THIRTY YEARS SENATOR DODD I
HAPPEN TO LIVE IN YOUR DISTRICT
. I'VE NEVER VOTED FOR A
REPUBLICAN BUT I WAS HAPPY TO
ACCEPT SENATOR MELINDA SAYS
INVITATION TO TESTIFY TODAY. THE
QUESTION POSED BY THIS
RESOLUTION IS NOTHING LESS THAN
WHETHER OUR STATE WILL ABANDON
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS BETWEEN
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
THAT IS ENSHRINED IN OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION. THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE AT LEAST IT
SHOULD NOT BE. TO BE CLEAR THIS
RESOLUTION IS NOT A REFERENDUM
ON ANY SPECIFIC PUBLIC HEALTH
POLICIES ARE IN GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S LEADERSHIP. THE
QUESTION POSED BY THIS
RESOLUTION IS NOT WHICH POLICY
SHOULD BE ENACTED BUT WHO SHOULD
BE CRAFTING THOSE POLICIES. OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT LIKE OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DESIGNED
TO USE CHECKS AND BALANCES TO
GUARD AGAINST THE INHERENT
DANGER OF ANY ONE PERSON GAINING
TOO MUCH POWER. THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT ALLOWS THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO TEMPORARILY
USURPED SOME LEGISLATIVE POWERS
WHEN THE PRICES REQUIRES SWIFT
ACTION. BUT IT REPRESENTS SUCH
AN EXTRAORDINARY DISRUPTION TO
THE BALANCE OF POWER THAT IT
MUST BE LIMITED IN DURATION. THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH SO FAR HAS
ESSENTIALLY PUNTED THE ISSUE
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ACCORDING TO THE THIRD DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEAL WOULD SAVE THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT FROM AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATION OF
THE SEPARATION OF POWERS IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE POWER
UNDER SECTION EIGHTY SIX TWENTY
NINE OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE. TO
TERMINATE THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IF THE CUB GOVERNOR REFUSES TO.
BUT IF THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT
WILLING TO CONSIDER AND GOOD
FAITH WHETHER THE EMERGENCY IS
OVER THE NOT SAFEGUARD IS
MEANINGLESS. TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE CRISIS IS A POWER GRAB GRAB
FOR THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS FAR
FROM NORMAL. THIS IS GONE ON
THROUGHOUT HISTORY AROUND THE
WORLD AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS
STATE LEGISLATURES AND COURTS
HAVE HAD TO REIGN IN THE ABUSE
OF EMERGENCY POWER. BY GOVERNORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AS PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN A RELATIVELY STABLE
SOCIETY WE OFTEN TAKE OUR
DEMOCRACY FOR GRANTED. BUT
DEMOCRACY IS FRAGILE. IF WE
NORMALIZE SUSPENDING OUR USUAL
LAW MAKING PROCESS FOR A LONG
LONG PERIOD OF TIME WE CHIP AWAY
AT THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DEMOCRACY AND
HEAD DOWN A DANGEROUS PATH. EACH
OF YOU HAS TAKEN A SOLEMN OATH
TO DEFEND THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THE DUTY OF YOUR
OFFICE COMPELS YOU TO RECLAIM
THE POWERS THAT THE CONSTITUTION
GRANTS ONLY TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WE URGE YOU TO PUT PRINCIPLE
ABOVE PARTY. AND VOTE ON A C. R.
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISSPELLED LET'S CONTINUE WITH
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN
THE CHAMBER MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PAUL YOUR ROOM WE HAVE THE
PLASTER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
S. C. R. FIVE THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE CHAMBER SEEING NONE
. WILL MOVE NOW ONTO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR%
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R. FIVE WE
WILL BE GETTING- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ROBERT OUR
FIRST LINE OF SUPPORT BY NUMBER
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEXT CALLER. PHOTO I.
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M TWENTY
SEVEN ARE YOU THERE. YEAH GOOD
MORNING THIS IS YOUR NUMBERS
THAT'S THE PREMIUM ACTUALLY
CALLING IT OPPOSITION. WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT. SH.
MODERATOR COULD YOU JUST MAKE A
NOTE HERE GO AHEAD YES. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HE
PREVIOUSLY SOLID CREW SHOT A
YOUNG MAN AS A RECORD OPPOSITION
DEATH YOUR FLOOR WE BELIEVE THAT
IT PREMATURELY ENDING EMERGENCY
DECLARATION UNNECESSARILY
UNDERMINES CURRENT STATE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU YOUR CALL SKEWS ME-
WERE IN IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW SO
I'M ASKING ANYBODY THAT'S IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. FIVE THAT
WANTS TO CALL IT GIVE THEIR NAME
THEIR LOCATION AND WHETHER THEY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. IN THEIR
SUPPORT- I HAD TO CALL IN NOW.
GO AHEAD MOTOR. REMEMBER TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I AM NICOLE YOUNG
WITH THE PLASTER COUNTY AT
MONTFORD LIBERTY AND WE ARE IN
THE COURT AS AN INTERNAL INDEXES
A C. R. RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT THIRTY ONE ALLEN
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BRAD
ANDERSON CITY IRAN'S RISE SINCE
IT IS THEN I'M IN SUPPORT OF S.
C. R. FIVE THANK YOU. ROBERT
LINE TWENTY SIX ALIGN IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE NO
REASON TO CUT ABOUT EIGHT TEN
MINUTES PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
CALL THROUGH THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE PHONE. TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND ALL OUR-
NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL LINES FOR SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU-
MODERATOR- HAVING HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORT NOW WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION WE'LL BEGIN WITH
MISTER BRIAN RICE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WHO IS HERE IN THE
CHAMBER SIR. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO S.
C. R. FIVE MY NAME'S BRIAN RCE
AND THE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. I DID
A THIRTYYEAR CAREER RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO I REPRESENT OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND CAREER
FIREFIGHTER PARAMEDICS EMERGENCY
SERVICE PERSONNEL. THE LAST TWO
YEARS COVERT NINETEEN IF TESTED
THE FIRE SERVICE IN WAYS THAT
NONE OF US EXPECTED BUT THE MEN
AND WOMEN SERVING THEIR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE STEPPED UP TO THE TASK AT
EVERY OPPORTUNITY. WHEN%
PROVIDING EMERGENCY CARE DURING
THE FIRST WAVE OF THE PANDEMIC
IN THE FOLLOWING SURGES STANDING
UP TESTING CLINICS AND HIGHLY
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES OR CREATING
MOBILE VACCINATION OR TESTING
EFFORTS TO REACH THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE DONE WHATEVER.
WAS NECESSARY TO KEEP THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA SAFE AND
HEALTHY. ALL THOSE EFFORTS AND
MORE WERE POSSIBLE DUE TO THE
FLEXIBILITY TOWARD LOCAL EMS
SYSTEMS LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
MORE BY THE STATE OF EMERGENCY.
AND THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS
IMPLEMENTED BY THE STATE. JUST
AS A PANDEMIC IS ON GOING IT'S
AN UNPRECEDENTED EMERGENCY FOR
OUR STATE IN THE WORLD. THE
RESPONSE. TO REQUIRED
UNPRECEDENTED ACTION TAKE SWIFT.
AND DECISIVE ACTION TO SAVE
LIVES EVEN. EVEN AS A KEY EVEN
AS CASE MORALITY NUMBERS
CONTINUE IMPROVE THE RECENT ON
THE CRIME SURGE AND ITS IMPACTS
ON THE EMS SYSTEM HAVE SHOWN HOW
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THESE
AUTHORITIES AND FLEXIBILITY
STILL REMAIN. AMBULANCES WITH
COVERT NINETEEN PATIENTS ALONG
WITH THOSE EXPERIENCING OTHER
HEALTH EMERGENCIES ARE WAITING
FOR HOURS AND HOURS IN EMERGENCY
ROOMS ON THE HALL WHAT WE CALL
WALL TIME. BEEN PART OF THIS IS
DUE TO THE INFLUX OF PATIENTS
WITH COPD NINETEEN. I'M GONNA
WRAP IT UP AND IT'S GOING TO
SAY. THIS IS NOT THE TIME FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO GET INVOLVED
IN EMERGENCY AS IT IS WINDING
DOWN THIS IS A VIRUS. THAT
MUTATES AND CHANGES ARE
EMERGENCY SERVICES SYSTEM IS
STILL VERY IMPACTED AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE GET OFF OF
THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS NOT ONLY IS
APPROPRIATE BUT NEEDS TO REMAIN
IN PLACE. AND I WOULD URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON S. C. R. FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE TO CATHERINE AUSTIN SCOTT
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS US ASSOCIATION ALSO
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING CAPTAIN
HOUSES GOT REMEMBER CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION REPRESENT
FOUR HUNDRED HOSPITALS PLUS
ACROSS THE STATE. WHO HAVE AS
OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND PARTNERS IN
HEALTH CARE BEEN FIGHTING. THIS
PANDEMIC FOR OVER TWO YEARS- AS
WE ARE SEEING SEES ME. THE. THIS
EMERGENCY IS NOT OVER AS WE ARE
SEEING. ON APOLOGIES. OUR
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN WORKING IN
LOCKSTEP WITH OUR HEALTHCARE
PARTNERS FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
TO MEET THIS CRISIS WE ARE
FACING UNPRECEDENTED WORK FORCE
SHORTAGES THIS GOVERNOR HAS PUT
BILLIONS INTO RESTORING OUR
WORKFORCE RETAINING WORKERS
BECAUSE WE HAVE LOST ALMOST 20%
OF OUR WORK FORCE IF IT WEREN'T
FOR THE WAIVERS THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY
WAIVER TO WAIVE THE TIMES
NECESSARY FOR OUR OUT OF STATE
WORKERS TO COME TO THIS STATE
THOUSANDS OF OUT OF STATE
WORKERS. WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
SERVE OUR PATIENTS AS WE HAVE
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
ADDITION AS A FIREFIGHTER
BROTHERS HAVE SAID OUR EMERGENCY
ROOMS ARE OVERLOADED BECAUSE OF
THOSE WAIVERS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WAVE SPACE AS WELL AS OUT OF
STATE WAIVERS AND BRING AN OUT
OF STATE WORKERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COULD SERVE THE PATIENTS
IN THOSE EMERGENCY ROOMS. IF
THIS. WAIVER WERE TO BE COMPLETE
ENDED TODAY WE WOULD LOSE THOSE
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS AND THAT'S
BASE OVERNIGHT. PATIENTS WOULD
BE. SEEING A LONGER WAIT TIMES
POTENTIALLY FORCING THEM TO WAIT
ON CARE- AND UNFORTUNATELY
WOULD. RESULT IN WORSE PATIENT
OUTCOMES FOR THIS REASON WE ARE.
I'M ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED TO THE-
ELIMINATION OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WAIVER AND LOOK FORWARD TO IT A
NO VOTE FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
SCOTT- THANKS TO THE MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
MOVE TO ANY OTHER WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
WE HAVE ONE GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON
BEHALF OF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION
THIS MORNING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MS LAG. NEXT THANK YOU
MISTER JERRY MARTIN MARTINEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MISTER MARTINEZ.
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE CHAMBER
SEEING NONE. WERE MOVED OUT-
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES OF CALL THE OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL
CONTINUE. IF SHE- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
CRYSTALLINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
RESEARCHER MEMBERS UNDERESTIMATE
AS ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND MAYOR
LIBBY SCHAAF AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THAT C. R. FIVE THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT EIGHTEEN NINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
MEMBERS NOT ONLY AFTER THE NEXT
MORNING. THE NEXT OVERLAND
SIXTEEN NINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MY NAME IS RUSSELL RAWLINGS
SAYING THE STATEWIDE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER AT CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF THE
DISABILITY ORGANIZING NETWORK IN
THE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS SERVED BY
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS. STRUGGLING FORTY
ONE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTERING
INTO HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
OPPOSITION. AXOLOTL LINE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND SHARE MY
NAME IS RUSSELL ALL THE GOOD
MORNING MR SURE THIS IS DAN
OPEN. DINING- YEAH I'LL BE- WE
ARE THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
STUDENT LIVING CENTERS
REPRESENTING- ABILITY- WHAT IS
THE RIGHT ORGANIZATION- AND
CALIFORNIA- TWENTY FIVE-
INTELLIGENCE OUR STOCKTAKE WE'RE
OPPOSITION. TO THE SP OF FIVE.
THANK YOU. RIGHT TWO LINE IS UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GENE HEARST
CALLING IN TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
THE LARGEST FOURTEEN COUNTIES IN
THE STATE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. EXCELLENT THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS JACKIE
GRAY WALL LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
WITH U. F. C. W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL AND STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR GOING
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
JACQUELINE ONE HERNANDEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES- REPRESENTING THE
COUNTIES AND AN ELECTED COUNTY
SUPERVISORS FOR ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES- CALLING IN AN
OPPOSITION. FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED IN THE LETTER THAT WE
SENT TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NINE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARKET THAT WHILE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL WE
WERE HOPING FOR A FEW SECONDS TO
ARTICULATE OUR CONCERNS ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPECIALISTS ARE
NUMBERED I'M SORRY. I DIDN'T
CATCH YOUR STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION SO YOU'RE TAKING
NO POSITION NEXT CALLER. FOR THE
NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU YEAH
NUMBERS AND SHARE MY NAME IS
LAURIE ENOUGH FROM ANOTHER
COUNTY CALIFORNIA MISTER BILL
DOG OFFICE REPRESENTING ST
MARTIN ISLAND AND WE ARE IN
FAVOR OF FIVE AND WE MISSED OUR
CALL. THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
TWENTY SEVEN NINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EXPELLING THIRTY EIGHT ALIGN IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA JAIL COMING TOGETHER
AGAIN. OF THE MILLION THE
PANELING PATTERN HERE IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. OR IN THE
OPPOSITION AND THE- FIRE LINE
THANK YOU. AN EXCELLENT TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY THIRTY THE
MAJOR PHONE. I HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL LINES AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
THANKS TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL BRING
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS-
DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
NELSON. THIS PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS ONE OF MOST IMPORTANT
BILLS BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE NOT
THIS YEAR BUT MANY YEARS. WHY
I'VE COMPLAINED OFTEN HEAR ABOUT
HOW THE EXECUTIVE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT STATE AND FEDERAL.
INCLUDING PRESIDENTS AND
GOVERNORS HAVE USURPED THROUGH
EMERGENCY ORDER AND GOVERNMENT
THROUGH EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS.
I REMEMBER VOTING FOR THE BILL.
IN READING THE BILL AS I OFTEN
DO. AND IT CONCERNS ME. OF NO
PROVISIONS I FELT OR TOO VAGUE
OF PROVISIONS ABOUT HOW THAT
THOSE ORDERS WOULD BE
EXTINGUISHED. WELL GOVERNORS AND
PRESIDENTS HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH THAT. THEY NOW HAVE
A LOT MORE POWER. YEAH WHOSE
POWER IS IT. NOT OURS THE
LEGISLATURE. ALREADY THE
GOVERNORS OF THE PRESIDENT'S THE
POWER OF THE CITIZENS. IT IS
TIME TO STOP FEEDING THAT
AUTHORITY TO THE AGENCIES ARE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE GOVERNORS AND PRESIDENTS
THIS IS URGENT WE REPRESENT
ABOUT A MILLION PEOPLE EACH OF
US. WE ARE THEIR VOICES HERE.
ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW THEIR
VOICES. TO BE SILENCED I ARGUE
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON. ANY OTHER
MEMBERSWISHING CENTER ALAN.
WELL MEMBER SITE I THINK THERE'S
SO MUCH THAT'S COMPELLING ABOUT
THIS BILL AND I UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE WOULD BE INCLINED TO
SUPPORT IT I THINK THAT THE ONE
PROBLEM HERE IS THAT DECLARING
THE EMERGENCY OVER- WOULD HINDER
OUR ABILITY TO DO A LOT THAT
INVOLVES. FIGHTING THIS PANDEMIC
I HAVE A THERE'S A BIG PIECE IN
THE LA TIMES YESTERDAY ABOUT
ABOUT THIS ISSUE AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL AND SO MANY OF THESE
ISSUES ARE AT PLAY HERE IN OUR
STATE LEVEL AS WELL IT WOULD
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR US TO
PROVIDE FREE. I. THERAPEUTICS
FOR EXAMPLE IN TESTING AND- ALL
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY A
NUMBER OF THE FOLKS WHO
TESTIFIED EARLIER TODAY SO I
JUST I. I COULD SEE MYSELF
SUPPORTING A SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMITED VERSION THIS BILL BUT
CERTAINLY NOT IN THE FORM. THAT
AS IT'S BEEN PRESENTED TODAY AND
I I'M NOT GONNA BE SUPPORTIVE
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO ADDRESS
COMMITTEE. I WAS AT YOU OVER
THERE SENATOR WELCOME PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MSTER CHAIR
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME COMING
AND I KNOW THAT HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH YOU I THINK YOU'RE GREAT
CHAIRMAN YOU RESPECT BOTH THE
MAJORITY AND THE MINORITY
MEMBERS EQUALLY AND SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS- FOR
THE AUTHOR SHE'S WILLING TO TAKE
THEM. AND SINCE IT'S NOT THE
FLOOR. I'M GOING TO ASK YOU- SO
FIRST- FIRST QUESTION I HAVE IF
S. C. R. FIVE WERE WERE TO PASS
TODAY WELL ANYTHING THIS BILL
PREVENTS THE GOVERNMENT FROM
TAKING RAPID ACTION IN THE
FUTURE SHOULD THE STATE
EXPERIENCED A SURGE IN KOBE
NINETEEN CASES HOSPITALIZATIONS
OR DEATHS. I THROUGH THE CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR WORK FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND THE ANSWER TO THAT
IS NO THERE IS NOTHING THAT
WOULD STOP- THIS BODY OR THE
GOVERNOR FROM TAKING ACTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY COULD SURGE
THAT MIGHT COME AT US IN THE
FUTURE WOULD NOT BE ADEQUATELY
AND APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED WE
STILL MAINTAIN THAT AUTHORITY
GREAT HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
IS THERE ANYTHING IN S. ZERO
FIVE THAT WOULD RESULT IN
CALIFORNIA BECOMING IN- TO
RECEIVE EMERGENCY THOUGHT.
FINDING THANK YOU SENATOR WOKE
TO THE CHAIR NOW THERE IS I KNOW
THAT THE OPPOSITION IS TRYING TO
PRESENT THIS AS THOUGH WE WILL
LOSE OUT ON- ALL THE FUNDING IN
THE RESOURCES THAT WE MIGHT NEED
IN THE FUTURE IF. ANOTHER SURGE
TAKES PLACE BUT THAT IS SIMPLY
NOT THE CASE AND I THINK THAT'S
FEAR MONGERING TACTICS THAT
APPARENTLY HAVE WORKED- QUITE
WELL BUT THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
THANK YOU STORE SO ON MY OWN
TIME. REALLY ENJOYED THE DEBATE
TODAY BECAUSE IF TODAY WAS
FASTER THIS I COULD I COULD LIST
THE GOVERNOR'S MISSTEPS HIS OVER
REACH ANY SECRET DEALS IN LIKE A
CATALOG THEM ALL FOR YOU BUT
IT'S NOT TESTED THIS I'M NOT
GONNA DO THAT. SO TO ME THIS IS
ALL ABOUT RESTORING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BALANCE. BETWEEN
THE THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT. AND TO SAY THAT WE
THINK WE CAN'T DO THAT WE JUST
DID THAT YESTERDAY IF YOU ALL
RECALL WE DIDN'T LIKE A COURT
CASE AND WE PASSED SB ONE
EIGHTEEN. WENT TO HOUSE THE SAME
DAY GOVERNOR SIGNED IT THE SAME
DAY. SO ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
TO GIVE THE PEOPLE'S VOICE BACK
ONE MAN RULE I THINK IT'S BEEN
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR SOCIETY. AND
IT'S GOING TO HAVE A CLOSE THE
FACT I THINK LONG TERM ON
GOVERNMENT. AND YOU KNOW AS WE
PULL AWAY FROM THIS CREDIT FROM
THIS CRISIS. I HOPE WE CAN. LOOK
BACK WITH LESS PASSION AND LOOK
TO SEE WHAT WE DID RIGHT AND
WHAT WE DID WRONG SO WE DON'T
MAKE THE SAME MISTAKES AGAIN I
MEAN I THINK TOO OFTEN. THE
GOVERNMENT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
WE JUST KIND OF YOU KNOW. YOU
LIKE CANCERS IN A WILL YOU KNOW
A CYCLING AROUND AND I THINK YOU
KNOW THE WORLD'S GETTING SMALLER
THROUGH GLOBALIZATION. I'M
ASSUMING WE'RE GONNA HAVE MORE
PANDEMICS NOT LAST IN WE DIDN'T
GET IT RIGHT THIS TIME. AND SO
WE HAVE A CHANCE AT LEAST GET
BACK ON. ON THAT ROAD BUT I
THINK THE MORE IMPORTANT THING
IS THAT. WE NEED TO FIX THE
THINGS SAID THAT WENT WRONG THIS
TIME BECAUSE A LOT PEOPLE PAID
DEARLY. WITH THEIR LIVES WITH
THEIR LOSS OF BUSINESSES WITH
THE WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SO
AGAIN. THIS RESTORE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BALANCE THAT THE
FRAMERS DESIGNED AND THAT HAS
WORKED WELL FOR SO MANY YEARS
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER WILL
- ALAN YEAH I LOOK I DO THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS BE
ENDED AT SOME POINT I GUESS THAT
I LET I WOULD LIKE TO ASK. THE
CHAIR MEET MAYBE IF ONE OF THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR THE OR
THE COMMITTEE STAFF COULD. COULD
RESPOND TO THE ANSWERS THAT WERE
GIVEN BY OUR COLLEAGUE ABOUT
FEDERAL FUNDING IN ABOUT- ABOUT
ABOUT POWER SAID THIS WOULD THIS
WOULD ROLL BACK IN TERMS OF OUR
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO RESPOND
TO THE PANDEMIC I WOULD LOVE TO
GET SOME SOME FURTHER
CLARIFICATION INFORMATION FROM-
FROM FROM EXPERTS ON THIS IS SO
WE CAN. AS YOU'RE EITHER ONE OF
THE PRESENTERS OR BOTH. PLEASE.
WHAT DOES. OKAY SIR YEAH. OKAY I
BELIEVE THE QUESTION HERE WAS
WHETHER THESE- THESE WOULD
EITHER BE CONTINUED OR OR
DEFINITIVELY ENDED THE- FEDERAL
FUNDING THE WAIVERS WE DISCUSSED
WITHOUT THE QUESTION SURE.
CENTER ALEXANDER ANSWERED SHE I
WOULD LIKE SOME CLARITY ON ON
FINDING AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
SOME CLARITY ON THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THIS WOULD WOULD HINDER
OUR ABILITY TO ACT QUICKLY. HOW
TO RESPOND TO CHANGES IN THE IN
THE IN THE- IN COVE IT AS IF
THERE'S ANOTHER SURGE OF CENTRAL
. SO A COUPLE OF ISSUES IF YOU
DON'T MIND WILL BOTH ANSWER ALL
TALK ABOUT THE HOSPITAL WAIVERS
AND THEN MAYBE- BRIAN YOU CAN
TALK ABOUT THE FIELD- FOR THE
HOSPITAL WAIVERS IT WOULD AND
SOME OF OUR FUNDING- BECAUSE WE
DO GET FUNDING THROUGH FEMA. IT
WOULD ALSO MORE IMPORTANTLY AND
THE WAIVERS I DISCUSS RELATED TO
BOTH OUT OF STATE. LICENSURE
THAT WOULD HAVE TO RUN. THAT
STRUCTURE CHANGES TO RUN THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE IN RECORD TIME-
THE SENATOR- DID MENTION THAT
THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN DONE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY GIVEN THE MASS
AMOUNT WOULD HAVE TO BE DONE-
THE MOST EFFICIENT WAY TO DO
THAT IS THROUGH. A PUBLIC-
EXECUTIVE ORDER- SO BOTH THE
HOSPITAL OUT OF STATE WAIVER AS
WELL AS THE SPACE WAIVER DETER
CRITICAL TO AGAIN. THE WALL TIME
ISSUES OF SEPARATING PATIENTS
PARTICULAR IMMUNO COMPROMISED
PATIENTS I AM IN ADDITION WHAT I
DIDN'T GET TO MENTION IS WE ARE.
SEEING A LOT OF PATIENTS COME IN
SICKER BECAUSE THEY DELAYED
CARE. SO WHILE THE NUMBERS MIGHT
BE GOING DOWN OUR HOSPITALS AND
EMS SYSTEMS ARE. HIGHLY IMPACTED
BECAUSE PATIENTS WAITED- LONGER
TO GET THEIR CARE AND ARE COMING
IN STICKER- SO THERE'S STILL THE
PUBLIC EMERGENCY- EXECUTIVE
ORDERS ALLOW THE GOVERNMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THIS AND- AND PULL
BACK INTO THE CONVERSATION. AS
WELL- MY COLLEAGUE. MISTER CHAIR
FOR THE FOR SERVICE ONE OF THE-
BIGGEST CONCERNS THAT WE WOULD
HAVE WOULD BE SOME OF THE- RULES
IN THE ADAPTATION OF RULES THAT
ALLOW US TO DO CERTAIN
PROCEDURES IN THE FIELD- THAT.
POTENTIALLY COULD GO AWAY AT A
TIME WHEN WE'RE STILL HIGHLY
IMPACTED- BY THE VIRUS. AND THE
PATIENTS THAT NEED OUR HELP THE
OTHER ONE IS- OUR ABILITY TO
ASSIGN FIELD PERSONNEL INTO
EMERGENCY ROOMS TO CONSOLIDATE
PATIENTS SOME OF THESE THINGS.
WE'RE NOT READY YET. AND WE'RE
NOT READY ON THE USER END AND MY
BIGGEST CONCERN WOULD BE FOR
CALIFORNIANS ARE WE ABLE TO GIVE
THE TYPE OF CARE THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE IT AWAY IT DOESN'T. MATTER
HOW FAST YOU CAN BRING IT BACK
IF YOU'RE TAKING IT AWAY WHEN IT
STILL NEEDED THAT'S THAT'S NOT
GOOD THAT'S NOT GOOD POLICY
WE'RE NOT THERE YET WE'RE CLOSE
BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET. THANK
YOU COULD I COULD WITH IT CAN I
ASK THAT THE WITNESSES STAND B
POLICE WITNESSES. I DO YOU HAVE
. IF YOU'RE ASKING US TO OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE- WHAT HOW LONG DO
YOU THINK WE OUGHT. HOW LONG DO
YOU THINK WE OUGHT TO BE
THINKING ABOUT- THE DURATION OF
THIS THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
DECLARATION- IF WE DO TURN THIS
DOWN TODAY WHAT STEPS SHOULD WE
TAKE. HI THAT WAS THAT SHE WOULD
BE TAKING TO MOVE RAPIDLY TOWARD
AN EVENTUAL RECISION OF THE
STATE AMER'S DIRECT REGULAR.
DECLARATION BRAIN RES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS I'M ON A WEEKLY
MONTHLY CALLS WITH HIGH LEVEL
OFFICIALS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- WITH THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. AND TRYING TO GAME
THIS OUT INTO THE FUTURE. AND I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US YOU'RE
QUALIFIED TO SEE WHEN THEY
SHOULD AND I THINK THAT. THE
GOVERNOR IN A DOCTOR GALLEY THEY
HAVE A TEAM IN PLACE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS MEDICAL SCIENTISTS
AND A DELIVERY SYSTEM- ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THAT ONE WE NEED TO
FOLLOW THEM AND WHEN THEY SAY
NOW IS THE TIME I THINK WE CAN
REST ASSURED AND BE READY THAT
IT'S YOUR PREPARATORY TO. REMOVE
THE ADVERT- THE- THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER I THINK WE NEED TO RELY ON
THE LEADERS THAT HAVE LETTUCE SO
FAR. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS MANY MEMBER CENTER
MONDAYS BEFORE YOU CLOSE I
WANTED TO OFFER A COUPLE OF THE
COMMENTS FIRST OF ALL WE'VE
HEARD HERE ABOUT- ABOUT THE
DIALOGUE ABOUT THE DEBATE TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE THAT- THE GOOD
STRONG DEBATE ON BOTH SIDES WHAT
WE CAN HAVE THIS- A DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT. YOU KNOW REALLY WHAT'S
GOING ON FOR WELL YOU KNOW I
HEAR THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T GET IT
RIGHT YEAH FRANKLY WHEN I LOOK
AT THIS AND I LOOK TO GO BACK
AND LOOK AT TWO YEARS OF THE
PANDEMIC I FOR ONE WE HAD NO
PLAYBOOK. NOBODY HAD A PLAYBOOK
ON THIS THING I THINK THE
GOVERNOR GOT RIGHT I THINK HE
CONTINUES TO GET IT RIGHT. AND
LOOK AT IT'S NOT THAT THERE'S NO
MISTAKES BEING MADE WERE ALL
HUMAN BEINGS WITH NO PLAYBOOK
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HOW STRONG THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN OUR
NUMBERS. ARE COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES THAT- WEREN'T DOING SOME
OF THE SAME THINGS- I FOR ONE AM
PROUD. OF THIS GOVERNOR FOR
DOING WHAT HE DID WE ALL KNOW
THE IMPACT THE COVERT NINETEEN
HAS HAD ON OUR DAILY LIVES. AND
I'M HAPPY TO SEE CASERATES AND
HOSPITALIZATION THAT LOW
NUMBERS- AND WE RETURN TO
NORMALIZATION OF LIFE. HOWEVER
THE EXISTING STATE OF EMERGENCY
PROCLAIMED BY THE GOVERNOR IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE CAN QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY CONTINUE TO RESPOND
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
IT BE PREPARED FOR POSSIBLE
FUTURE VARIANTS AND SURGEONS.
TODAY THERE ARE SIXTY THREE
PROVISIONS RELATING TO COPE AT
NINETEEN STATE OF EMERGENCY.
EIGHTEEN OF THOSE ARE SCHEDULED
TO BE TERMINATED AT THE END OF
THIS MONTH IN ANOTHER FIFTEEN AT
THE END OF JUNE LEAVING OPEN
THIRTY PROVISIONS IMPORTANT. FOR
MAINTAINING GOVERNMENT
FLEXIBILITY. I LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT IN ADDITION TO THE ONGOING
STATE OF EMERGENCY. THEY'RE
CURRENTLY ALMOST FIFTY OPEN
STATE OF EMERGENCIES REGARDING
SIT VARIOUS SITUATIONS INCLUDING
WILDFIRES DROUGHT. TREE
MORTALITY AND THE ORVILLE DAM
SPILLWAY EMERGENCY. THESE STATES
OF EMERGENCY PROVIDE THE STATE
WITH THE ABILITY TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY CARRY OUT CLEAN UP
RECOVERY AND MITIGATION OF
LASTING. NEGATIVE IMPACTS
FURTHER OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
PREVIOUSLY CONFERRED AUTHORITY
TO THE STATE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCIES TO ISSUE ORDERS. IN
RESPOND TO AND CONTROL THE
SPREAD OF TRANSMISSIBLE DISEASE.
THIS INCLUDES ORDERS FROM THE-
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPOSING MASKING REQUIREMENTS
AND TESTING AND VACCINATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR CERTAIN
SETTINGS. THUS IF THIS
RESOLUTION WERE TO BE ADOPTED
WOULD HAVE NO IMPACT ON THE
STATE LOCAL MASKING REQUIREMENTS
OR OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS.
FOR THOSE REASONS FOR NUMBER
REASONS POINTED OUT BY VARIOUS
SPEAKERS IN THE OPPOSITION. I'LL
BE VOTING NO TODAY ON S. C. R.
FIVE AND LAST MY MEMBERS TO DO
THE SAME. WITH THAT SAID SEND
REMINDERS WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. I
WOULD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR QUESTIONS IN
THE- ROBUST DEBATE I HAVE A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT I NEED TO
ADDRESS IN MY CLOTHES- I. I WANT
TO REMIND YOU SENATORS A THIRD
TWENTY NINE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE ENDED THEIR STATE OF
EMERGENCY ARE THEY ALL NOW AT
RISK. IF THERE IS A CODE RED
SERGE. DO YOU THINK THAT THEY
HAVE NOT CONTEMPLATED WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN. IF THEY HAVE ANOTHER
SURGEON THEY DON'T HAVE A STATE
OF EMERGENCY IN PLACE TWENTY
NINE OTHER STATES. SO THEY ARE
PUTTING THEIR CONSTITUENTS AT
RISK. THE THE OTHER EIGHT POINT
I'D LIKE TO MAKE IS THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S SUCH A THING
CALLED. A STATE OF EMERGENCY
DECLARED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
FACT I HAD ONE RECENTLY IN MY
OWN CITY WHERE WE HAD A FIRE. WE
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
THEN THE STATE KICKS IN AND THEN
FEMA CAN KICK IN AND
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE MADE AND
EVERYONE IS TAKING CARE OF.
THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD BE. AND
THAT IS STILL THE CASE TODAY WE
DON'T HAVE A STATEWIDE SURGE OF
COVERED RIGHT NOW WE MAY NOT
HAVE ANOTHER STATEWIDE SURGE OF
COVERAGE SO RATHER THAN. USE
THIS ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
OF KEEPING THE ENTIRE STATE IN A
STATE OF EMERGENCY WHY NOT
LOCALIZE IT WHY NOT ALLOW LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. IF THEY HAVE A
SURGE IF THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
DIFFICULTY WITH CAPACITY IN
THEIR HOSPITALS OR OTHER
SERVICES. ALLOW THEM TO DECLARE
STATE OF EMERGENCY AND THEN THE
STATE CAN STEP IN AND HELP IN
THE FEDS CAN STEP IN AND HELP IF
NECESSARY. BUT TO DO SO. YOU
KNOW IT INTO ETERNITY DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE I MEAN I'M
LISTENING TO THE OPPOSITION THEY
WILL THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHEN. THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY **** AND
THEY'RE NOT QUALIFIED TO SAY SO.
SO IT GOES ON FOREVER. BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE SUGGESTION WAS
TODAY THAT IT JUST GOES ON
FOREVER UNTIL DOCTOR DAILY OR
SOMEBODY ELSE IN PUBLIC HEALTH
DECIDES THAT IT'S OVER- THERE
WERE SOME OPPOSITION LETTERS
SENT IN AND A FEW OF THEM HAD
SOME REALLY SHOCKING- CLAIMS IN
HERE THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS AND I KNOW ALL OF YOU
HAVE RECEIVED. THESE OPPOSITION
LETTERS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS- CLAIMED IT WAS THAT
PHARMACIES AND PHARMACY TECHS
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES AND BOOSTERS. THAT IS
NONSENSE ANDI HOPE YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT IF THAT WERE THE
CASE HOW IS IT THAT OUR
PHARMACIES AND PHARMACY TECHS
HAVE BEEN ADMINISTERING FLU
SHOTS. HAVEN'T BEEN MINISTERING
SHINGLES VACCINATION HOW THEY'VE
BEEN DOING THAT ABSENT A STATE
OF EMERGENCY. WE'VE BEEN DOING
THAT AS FAR AS A SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA I THANK THE
OPPOSITION FOR RECOGNIZING THAT
WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF MEDICAL
PERSONNEL IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT
HAS BEEN THE CASE. FOR A DECADE
NOW AT LEAST IT IS NO SECRET
THAT WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
REGISTERED NURSES IN CALIFORNIA
WE BRING THE MEN ALL THE TIME IN
NOTHING. AND S. E. R. FIVE WOULD
PROHIBIT THOSE OUT OF STATE
WORKERS FROM BEING ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO COME IN AND HELP
WHERE NECESSARY NOTHING IN THIS
BILL. PROHIBITS THAT. ONE OF THE
OTHER CLAIMS MADE ABOUT THE
SPACE WAIVERS. YOU KNOW SENATOR
WELCOME WHEN I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE YOU MADE A
POINT THAT I WAS THINKING ABOUT
AS THE OPPOSITION WAS MOUNTING
THEIR CLAIM THAT WE WOULD
SUDDENLY LOSE THE WAIVERS FOR
ALL OF THE SPACES AGAIN
NONSENSE- THE LEGISLATURE COULD
TOMORROW. INTRODUCED LEGISLATION
TO IMPLEMENT THESE VERY WAIVERS
THERE IS NOTHING STOPPING US
FROM DOING THAT WE DID IT
YESTERDAY AND THAT WAS JUST FOR-
ENROLLMENT AT UC BERKELEY. AND
BOY THE LEGISLATURE WENT LIKE
LIGHTNING SPEED TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM THAT WASN'T EVEN AN
ISSUE WHERE PEOPLE'S HEALTH WAS
CONCERNED SO YOU'RE TELLING ME
THE OPPOSITION WOULD HAVE US
BELIEVE THAT THIS BODY IS
INCAPABLE OF DOING THE SAME
THING WHEN IT COMES TO PEOPLE'S
HEALTH REALLY BECAUSE I TAKE
OFFENSE TO THAT. AND YOU SHOULD
TOO. M. THE OTHER. CLAIM THAT
WAS MADE OUT OF THERE I MEAN
I'VE GOT MORE LETTERS HERE THAN
I KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH AND I
CAN'T ADDRESS ALL OF THEM.
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WHAT I'M JUST
GOING TO GO TO MY CLOTHES
BECAUSE I COULD GO ON FOR HOURS
REFUTING THE CLAIMS THAT WERE
MADE SENATOR DODD I DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT TO YOU SO I WILL GO
TO MY CLOTHES BUT I WILL. TELL
YOU SENATORS THAT I KNOW. THAT
THE OPPOSITION HAS. MADE SOME
VERY DIRE CLAIMS AND THEIR
OPPOSITION LETTERS AND I AM
BEGGING YOU. TO SEE THROUGH
THAT. LISTEN TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS RECOGNIZE THIS FOR
WHAT THIS IS THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN. BILL IT'S JUST NOT YOU
THOSE OF YOU WHO WHO ARE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE ALL OF THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE YOU HAVE
HEARD FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS I
KNOW YOU HAVE BECAUSE I'VE
SPOKEN WITH YOU. AND YOU KNOW
THAT YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE FED
UP WITH THIS AS WELL AND JUST.
CONSIDER FOR A MOMENT THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT THAT BEING
IN A CONSTANT STATE OF EMERGENCY
HAS. ON YOUR CONSTITUENTS HAS ON
YOUR CHILDREN HAS ON YOUR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M GOOD KIDS IN MY
DISTRICT WHO NEED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THEY NEED TO SEE. A
PSYCHOLOGIST THEY ARE STRUGGLING
MIGHTILY WITH THIS. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY CAN'T GET IN TO SEE.
SOMEONE TO COUNSEL THEM. THEY
CAN'T GO IN PERSON TO SEE
SOMEONE. BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
TAKING IN PERSON PATIENTS
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE OF IT. SO IF
YOU REMOVE THIS BARRIER JUST
FROM A PSYCHOLOGICAL STANDPOINT
MY GOODNESS LOOK AT. THE HELP
THAT YOU CAN BE DOING FOR SO
MANY OF THESE KIDS. I'LL
CONTINUE WITH MY CLOTHES. AND
I'M NOT SURE WHAT'S SO FUNNY ON
THIS SIDE OF THE ROOM BUT I WILL
CONTINUE I FIRST WANT TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION FOR PRO TEM
ATKINS AND THE CHAIRMAN FOR
SETTING THIS RESOLUTION FOR
HEARING IT IS BEEN A LONG TIME
COMING- AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT
. SENATORS THIS MEASURE AS
YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY ON THE
SENATE FLOOR IS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED DAYS OLD. AND THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY HAS BEEN IN PLACE
FOR OVER SEVEN HUNDRED DAYS IN
FACT THE STATE OF EMERGENCY HAS
BEEN EXTENDED THREE TIMES SINCE
IT WAS FIRST ENACTED IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY. THIS RESOLUTION
IS ABOUT ONE THING AND ONE THING
ONLY AND THAT I THE BALANCE OF
POWER. THE BALANCE BETWEEN
EXECUTIVE POWER AND LEGISLATION
LEGISLATIVE POWER TO BE PRECISE.
MANY OF THE GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO OPPOSE THIS
RESOLUTION THINK THAT THE
STATE'S COVERT RESPONSE WILL
COME TO A CRASHING HALT AND IT
DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL STILL HAVE THE
POWER TO DECLARE A LOCAL STATE
OF EMERGENCY IS TO NOTIFY THE
STATE THAT THEY ARE UNABLE TO
MEET A POTENTIAL SURGE. OF A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FEELS EMERGENCY
ORDERS ARE NECESSARY TO TACKLE
AN OUTBREAK OR TRIAGE MEDICAL
RESOURCES AN EMERGENCY ORDER BY
THE LOCALS ENGAGES STATE
RESOURCES. THIS IS PRECISELY HOW
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT WORKS FOR
WILDFIRES IN PRETTY MUCH ANY
OTHER DECLARED EMERGENCY. SO
WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE
GOVERNOR'S OWN WORDS OF LOCALISM
IS DETERMINATIVE. DURING HIS
SMARTER PRESS CONFERENCE. THEN
LETTING LOCALS DECIDE. IS WHAT'S
BEST LET'S TAKE FOR SECOND LET'S
CONSIDER THE OPPOSITION IS
CORRECT JUST FOR THE SAKE OF
ARGUMENT AND ASSUMING THAT ALL
OF THESE THINGS COME TO A
CRASHING HALT HAVE WE NOT SPENT
THE LAST TWO YEARS. PREPARING
PREPARING THE STATE FOR THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE HAVE WE'VE
DONE NOTHING IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS ARE WE CAUGHT COMPLETELY
FLAT FOOTED BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THE SUGGESTION IS THE GOVERNOR
IN HIS STATE OF THE STATE IN HIS
SMARTER PRESS CONFERENCE INSURED
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE ARE READY
AS YOUR FIVE DOES NOT LIMIT THE
GOVERNOR'S POWER TO ISSUE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS IT JUST
DOESN'T. IF WE BELIEVE THE
OPPOSITION'S CLAIMS THEY ARE
INHERENTLY SAYING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN. INCAPABLE OF
DOING ITS JOB EDITING CAPABLE OF
RESPONDING TO EMERGENCIES ARE
GIVING COMMUNITIES THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO ADDRESS CRITICAL
SITUATIONS. AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT AND I HOPE YOU DON'T EACH
LEGISLATOR IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE AGREED AT THE BEGINNING
OF THIS PANDEMIC TO GRANT THE
GOVERNOR WITH EMERGENCY POWERS
TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS AT HAND
BECAUSE IN THE FIRST DAYS OF
COVERED NOBODY KNEW WHAT WE WERE
DEALING WITH. HEALTH EXPERTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND ACROSS
THE WORLD WERE ATTEMPTING TO
DECIPHER THE GENETIC CODE OF
THIS BUYERS TO DETERMINE HOW IT
WORKED. WE DIDN'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS THE CHAIRMAN WAS RIGHT
ABOUT THAT. AND MISTAKES WERE
MADE AND WE LEARN FROM THOSE
MISTAKES. BUT WE ENDED SCHOOL
YEARS AND WE SHUTTERED
BUSINESSES AND WE IMPLEMENTED
LOCKDOWNS AND REINFORCED REMOTE
WORK AND WE IMPLEMENTED ALL
SORTS OF POLICIES IN TESTING AND
NOW AFTER TWO YEARS. OF THIS. WE
HAVE BECOME INCREDIBLY MORE
AWARE. OF HOW THIS VIRUS SPREADS
AND ITS IMPACTS. AND IT'S
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND THE
IMPACT ON THEM. WE HAVE GROWN
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE ARE
EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH THIS IN
THIS CONSTANT STATE OF EMERGENCY
IS NO LONGER NECESSARY. THERE IS
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM HERE TODAY
NO ONE. WHO WANTS ANYBODY TO
SUCCUMB. TO KEVIN NINETEEN. THE
SUGGESTION BY SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT THAT IS THE CASE
IS INSULTING. WHAT METRIC WHAT
GOAL POST WHAT MILESTONE WITH
DATA SET IS GOING TO BE USED TO
DETERMINE WHEN THIS ENDS NO ONE
CAN GIVE US THAT ANSWER. THIS
EMERGENCY IS NOT A WILDFIRE IT'S
NOT A DROUGHT IT IS NOT AN OIL
SPILL INTO SOMETHING ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT. IF AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION ARISES FROM CODE OR
ANY OTHER DISEASE OUTSIDE A PAN
PAN TO MAKE. DO YOU THINK THAT
WE CAN'T SOLVE THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S SORT OF THE VIBE THAT I'M
GETTING TODAY. WE ARE ELECTED TO
REPRESENT NEARLY ONE MILLION
PEOPLE AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY. TO SPEAK TO END
THIS. AT THE SAME TIME INSURING
THEM THAT WE WILL BE READY AND
PREPARED TO ADDRESS ANY NEEDS
THAT MAY ARISE IN THE FUTURE OR
MAY NOT ARISE. IT IS TIME TO
FOLLOW THE LEAD OF TWENTY NINE
OTHER STATES AND IN THE STATE OF
CONSTITUENTS AND MINE I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU MR.
THANK YOU SENATOR MELENDEZ- WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS. CENTER
ARCH ALETTA MOVES THE BILL. THE
MOTION- IS FOR THE RESOLUTION TO
BE ADOPTED SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FILING FOR A
C. R. FIVE THROUGH MOTION AS FOR
THE RESOLUTION TO BE ADOPTED
DAUGHTER. NO DIAGNOSE NIELSEN
ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI ALAN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA KNOW BECKER
. YEAH BECKER NOVARTIS. BRADFORD
GLAZER WEST SO- WESTERN NOTES
JONES HI JONES HI KEN LONGER
MELENDEZ. MILLY'S ELEVEN I
POURED INTO NOW NO ACCORDING TO
NO NO RUBIO. RUBIO NO WELCOME HI
WELL I TERMINA HAS FOUR TO SIX
ON CALL. ABOUT THE BILLS ON CALL. WE KNOW WORST CENTER BRADFORD. THANK YOU. BUT WE DO THAT.
WE'LL LET. IF THE CALL ON THE
BILLS ALLOW THOSE PEOPLE THAT
ARE HERE RIGHT NOW TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE MOVE ON FOR THE REST OF
THEIR DAY. I THINK I WILL. SORRY
I MISSED YOUR PRESENTATION. AND
ACTOR PLEASE. CALL THE BILLS. I
GOT IT OUT. WHEN I START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR GERMAN YES
PLEASE. BUT REMEMBERS THIS IS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT
MEMBERS ALAN. ALLEN ALLEN ALLEN
FILE IN HI GORGEOUS RADFORD
GLAZER LATER HI WENT SO I WENT
SO I PUT INTO YOU KNOW HI
ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW I PUT THAT
ON COURTROOM. OKAY WITH- THE
SPOT BILL STILL ON CALL WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
S. B. EIGHT FORTY SIX SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE ON FILE ONE
SB FORTY SIX. OKAY MEMBERS THIS
IS FOLLOWED HIM ONE S. B. A.
FORTY SIX ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA. GORGEOUS OXFORD
BLAZER BLAZER I CAN LONGER STILL
ON PARCHMENT. GOES ON CALL NOW
MOOD FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AT C.
R. FIVE SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ON FILE FOR YES YOU ARE
FIVE SO THIS IS A FINAL ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. C. R. FIVE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALAN. BORJAS BRADFORD
BLAZER. CAMELOT- I'M FORTUNATE.
THE BILLS I CALL. YOU WANT TO
ROLL THAT ONE OVER COULD WE
COULD WE RECALL THE ROLE IN THAT
LAST BILL PLEASE. S. C. R. FIVE
SURE. THIS IS- FOLLOWED A NUMBER
FOR A C. R. FIVE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN. FORGERS BRADFORD GLASER
CAN LONGER CATALOG OR NO. THE
BILLS ON CALL- YES WE CAN OPEN
IT AGAIN.
SENATOR MELINDA IS PLEASED YES I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANTED TO REQUEST SHOULD THIS
SHOULD S. C. R. FIVE NOT HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET THROUGH
COMMITTEE TODAY IF I COULD GET
RECONSIDERATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION WOULD
BE GRANTED THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE OF
VITAMIN FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SP
EIGHT FORTY SIX SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE PLEASE YES FOLLOW
HIM ONE SB EIGHT FORTY SIX
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA. FORGES
BRADFORD. CALENDAR CAMERA HIGH
ON CULTURE. THOSE ON CALL. AT
THIS POINT- WE'RE GOING TO-
RECESS IS BEATING FOR PROBABLY
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES OR SO UNTIL-
SENATOR BRADFORD- RETURNS TO THE
FLOOR.
TO- SESSION ENDOWED SKEWS ME TO-
IN ORDER OF WHAT THE COMMITTEE
IS NOW BACK TO ORDER SO WILL- MR
SECRETARY COULD YOU. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. LET'S START WITH THE
CONSENT ITEMS PLEASE YES THIS IS
OUR FINAL ITEM ONE WHICH IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ABSENT MEMBERS
GORGEOUS BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI
CHAIRMAN THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE S.
P. FORTY SIX SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ON FILE NUMBER ONE
HAS TO BE EIGHT FORTY SIX THIS
IS FOLLOWED HIM ONE SB A FORTY
SIX ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
BORDERS BRADFORD. BRADFORD I MET
THE CHAIRMAN THAT IS THIRTEEN
TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT. THE
BILLS THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE NOW MOVE ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. C. R. FIVE
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
ON. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. C.
R. FIVE THIS IS ALL I'VE KNOWN
FOR A C. R. FIVE. CHAIR VOTING
NO VICE CHAIRMAN VOTING HI I
HAVE SOME MEMBERS ALAN GORGEOUS
BRADFORD. BRADFORD NO. PLEASE
REMEMBER THAT OUR CHAIRMAN THAT
HAS. ONE TWO THREE FOUR FOUR
TWO. FOUR TO EIGHT THE MEASURE
FAILS. THAT AS SECRETARY SAID
THAT RESOLUTION FAILS THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY THE
FISHEL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION IF. YOU READ. IN
THE FOURTH FOR THE RECORD AS
WELL AS I'D DONE EARLIER WE DID
GRANT I DID GRANT-
RECONSIDERATION ON S. C. A.
FIVE. SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION IS
A JERK.